Lánh nào viện 5 thao vừa đến chiếc bộn với gia đình, anh đạo ZZ-1,
xinh năm 2020, chiến trăm chimét thơ, người đã từ vào phía số cảm cứu học xinh bị đối nước vào mùi bốn dở húng qua,
hai người tháng 6.
Thờ đó, các bố học xinh cùng xinh năm 2020, đạo dụng nhau giả bại bội xong hồng,
thuộc khuôn năm, giả cọng giá để tấm và bị đối nước.
Ngay sau khi thế có tiếng hồ quán tiêu cứu, anh đạo ZZ-1 và anh đến vải sang,
đăng đến cá tần đó của một số người dân đã giống cảm năng xuống xong,
kịt ơi cứu và đưa bốn cho bế và bữa ăn toàn.
Tuy nhiên, sau được kịt nước quán sái, anh đạo ZZ-1 đã kịt sức bị giống nước quán chôi và tử vong.
Anh giống gia đi khi tuổi đời con trẻ, chương lập gia đình để lại lối sốt xa khôn muôi cho trà mẹ.
gia đình anh thuộc dịnh hộ nhau có người em trai bị uống thư.
Nhằm đổ viên tình thần giống cảm và chia sẻ với những khó khăn mất mắt của gia đình,
lãnh hảo viên đâm thao đã chào số tiền 25 triệu đồng từ 1 quyết bảo trở sát hội,
1 trở đồng từ quyết viên người ngào của huyện cho gia đình anh.
Nếu tổ chức bản thể, cá nhân của viên đâm thao và giá có sáng, cuộc đặt tới triệu bộn đổ viên gia đình.
Gòn thích niên cậu sản hủ chi Minh quyết đâm thao, cũng báo cáo tình đoàn và huyên đâm thao,
để nghề có hình thức truy tàng của ở đối phê anh đạo xí suanh, viên đạo số tàng cứu người.